right getting into your dream home may
be easier after some changes that went
into effect this month to tell us more
about that we're joined by Kirby
Scofield owner of Scofield Realty the
sponsors of this segment Kirby thanks
for being here thank you for having me
the changes we're talking about involve
private mortgage insurance first of all
what is that uh private mortgage
insurance is basically insurance you
have to get if you have less than 20
down to protect the lender okay in case
you don't in case you default so that
has been lowered that has been lowered
yes which makes it more affordable for a
lot of people yeah so it was lowered by
30 basis points from 80 base points to
uh 50 which in return on an average
house right now with our FHA limit which
is 512 that you can get 123 dollars in
savings a month from a month ago so
significant it's significant it can
either make you afford more or your debt
to income ratio change now so if you're
looking for a house a month two months
ago that may have been just on the cusp
out of your affordability you may be
able to afford it now is this true of
homes of any price or does is there a
limit no no it's any price of FHA and
the conventional limits uh VA still has
their funding fee of the 1.75 that did
not change yet there's word it may but
for the FHA and conventional uh funding
fee it has or the PMI okay so you have
three options then when it comes to the
VA uh am I correct yeah yeah VA FHA and
conventional okay yeah all right and so
how do you know which one is which for
you so with a client you'll know because
VA is your anyone who's a military a
veteran a family veteran and you're
without loan you're the 100 covered I
mean of course you put down payments 100
covered and it's 1.75 funding fee but as
far as FHA that's your traditional what
you here the first time home buyer but
you don't have to be a first-time
homebuyer to get it okay so it's a
normal three and a half percent down but
with rates constantly going up and all
we hear is the news on that when you're
attacking a rate that say was six
percent but now you're saving 30 basis
points maybe you're at 5.7 now right you
know so it changes everything because
that's still a percentage of the total
loan is how it's based off of it so how
can people figure out what numbers are
what the best am I allowed to plug my
person absolutely 100. so hit up Robert
Coomer group uh they will take care of
you their VA Specialists and FHA
Specialists you name it but uh they're
actually the ones that provide me all
this information so it comes from the
experts from the FED how it works and um
that first step is talk to one of our
agents and then with the link all right
Kirby thanks so much appreciate you
being here today look forward to seeing
you again and we want to thank Scofield
Realty for sponsoring this segment if
you want more information you can visit
scofieldrealty.com or call that number
on the lower part of the screen
702-941-7202 and